حادثه غريبه اثارت ضجه واسعه في اسبانيا
الممثله انا اوبراغون تصبح جددا واما
للمولود نفسه بعدما انجب ابنها المتوفي
حفيدتها انا نشات الى تقنيه تاجيل الارحام
لتحقيق ما تقول انه اخر امنيه لابنها الذي
توفي بالسرطان عن عمر 27 عاما وهي انجاب
طفل انا استخدمت عينات من الحيوانات
المنويه لابنها لتلقيح بويضه ام بديله
تعيش فلوريدا لكن ما فعلته يعد غير قانوني
في اسبانيا فلا يمكن استخدام عينات
الحيوانات المنويه الا لتلقيح شريكه ارمله
خلال سنه من وفاه المتبرع بذن صريح الا ان
الممثله الاسبانيه قالت انها استقبلت
مولوده اسمتها ان ساندرا في العشرين من
مارس الماضي في ميامي ولديها وثائق تثبت
انها معترف بها قانونيا كام لطفله في
امريكا